i think the obvious you know elephant in
the room is the
ew factor um of of insects and i think
you know one of the points that that
you speak about is you know really you
know we're eating prawns we're eating
lobsters we're eating we're eating all
these bugs from the sea and they're
actually you know some of our greatest
delicacies
in many cases um and we somehow don't
have an
uh the same response to that that we do
i think in western culture at least to
eating crickets i just wonder if you
could
expand on that and i know that you found
that so much of the world population is
eating
insects and possibly vastly more than
even as being reported so i just
if you can talk a little bit more about
how those two things come together right
so how to develop good habits of eating
insects
well i would suggest you start off as a
snack food
you know it's it's actually really tasty
um to eat that and if they're
already dead and in in a spicy maybe or
vanilla
or something kind of uh sauce with it
it's actually
you'll love it just as much as you like
snacking on doritos it's uh
that's your thing it's actually quite
quite delicious and i think the the hard
part is just to try it
now maybe it'll be easier if we just
change the name we don't call them
insects anymore we call them land shrimp
and
and then that will help you get over it
but
we don't actually have the culture of
of eating insects here but we actually
do have a culture of
of trying something new so
i think just being willing to try it
once
opens you up to it and in madagascar
we i'm always surprised that you know
when we introduce it there
is our worry well are they going to eat
it but that's
never been an issue like when you
presented to
all 400 kids at the school the teachers
are like
i don't know about this but no kid says
that
they're in it it's a learned it's a
learn to eat yeah
because they still every kid when
they're you know below the age of 13
have eaten it
but it it but i love that that's a
coondri it's a delicious bacony taste
and
you know if that's he just you know i'm
a type of person who loves to snack when
i write or work so i
i couldn't i'd prefer to eat
secondry than uh popcorn well yeah that
the idea of a bacon bug is definitely
you know converting me on that uh in a
huge way
and and i remember just being in oaxaca
it wasn't until several days in that i
realized that the salt that i was
having with all of the the mezcal is a
cricket based
uh this amazing cricket based salt and i
was like all right well i guess i'm
eating insects
um and it kind of it changed you know
really the form factor of powder
and that change it you know where it
doesn't have legs and all that um and
once you've done it you realize it's
delicious and
and it's you know it's it's as good as
prawns really